welcome back to our music's biggest
weekend special antoine amadeus thompson
is a multi-platinum record producer
musician and author of the new book and
the beat goes on and the list of
accomplishments goes on as well but that
would take an entire show that would
take the entire trip welcome to the show
thank you so much for having me i'm
honored thank you so much this is
awesome oh my gosh please we are so
excited to talk to you so before we get
to the book okay before we get to the
book let's talk grammys
you have worked with so many different
grammy award-winning artists what does
this weekend mean to you guys in the
music community it's like the one of the
biggest moments ever you worked so hard
musically in the studio countless hours
you know trying to create music that you
can appreciate that the fans can
appreciate so to be celebrated for your
hard work and labors is one of the
greatest feelings ever wow okay well are
you ready to play a grammy game oh yeah
we're gonna play this in las vegas now
we play games on the show oh man okay
okay all right so i'm gonna name some of
the you know grammy award-winning
artists you've worked with and then the
first word that comes to mind
when you hear the name okay okay
anything anything you know that's p pg
pg-13 okay it's a family show okay first
one
p diddy and this and you're under bad
boy's label so this is boss man so be
careful
man that's like you said one word not
already not listening icon oh i like
that i like that okay justin timberlake
one of my favorites
smooth oh then what song did you did you
do for him so just touring just touring
not not necessarily producing but just
touring on the same bills performing on
the same shows in front of the same
people so to be able to great stages
that
justin timberlake is has performed on is
pretty epic
he's a drummer so we'll get to that
scene too jay-z
brooklyn oh okay okay
all right chris brown one of my
favorites legend legend all right and
grammy nominated not winner but grammy
nominated and you have a vegas
connection here j.lo
i got to do two words bronx queen okay
we'll take it and you you are a drummer
at dre's nightclub here in vegas so how
did you get that opportunity and how can
we see you i've been toying with trey
songz for 15 years all around the world
uh he has a residency there as well
right before hitting the stage that
night the owner is sitting inside of the
victor dre the owner and he's like hey
man why don't you just jump on the drums
and play with the dj a little bit shout
out to dj friends and that's how that
came about and after the show he's like
hey uh you want a residency here and i'm
like what does that mean exactly you
know now we know what it means because
we're showing you video right now
so this weekend we can catch you at dre
with the grammy weekend party all the
stars will be on stage but before we get
done we got to talk about the books so
introduce us to the story of amadeus
what people can expect and who is it for
i i genuinely wrote it for kids
just to inspire them to chase and live
their dreams like how i'm doing i've
been in the music industry for over 20
plus years a lot of blood sweat and
tears hard work labor
sleepless nights
you know wanting to be where i am where
i'm at today and you know i'm from a
very tough neighborhood uh so people
expect expect us to be in jail and
locked up and doing all kind of negative
things and i just kind of wanted to
break the stereotype and live my dreams
which is music and just inspire people
to go after what it is whatever it is
that they love and most passionate about
so it's for kids but a lot of the adults
are appreciating it too because
sometimes adults feel like you know once
they reach a certain age it's over for
them and i don't believe in that if you
have life and you have breath in your
body that's another opportunity for you
to leave your dream live your dreams as
well so that is beautiful and where can
people get the book really quickly
www.iamkingamadeus.com
www.iamkingammadays.com